[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos en
esta edición vamos a tratar varias
iniciativas tecnológicas y científicas
amigables con el medio ambiente
en principio hablamos de los nóveles de
física y química ambos entregados por la
academia sueca de las ciencias a
iniciativas relacionadas con la crisis
climática el de física fue otorgado a
seguro manabe klaus hasselmann y giorgio
parís y cuyo trabajo ayuda a comprender
sistemas físicos complejos como el clima
de la tierra puntualmente el premio se
divide en dos
tres la mitad del premio en conjunto va
para seguro manabí klaus hasselmann por
el modelado físico del clima de la
tierra cuantificando la variabilidad y
prediciendo de manera confiable el
calentamiento global
para giorgio parís por el descubrimiento
de la interacción y del desorden y las
fluctuaciones en los sistemas físicos
desde escalas atómicas a planetarias
saint louis gates en otras palabras el
japonés manabe demostró como el aumento
de los niveles de dióxido de carbono en
la atmósfera conllevan a un incremento
de las temperaturas en la superficie de
la tierra
posteriormente hasselmann creó un modelo
que vincula el tiempo y el clima con el
que demostró que los modelos climáticos
pueden ser confiables pese a que el
tiempo es cambiante y caótico también
desarrolló métodos que identifican
señales específicas que dejan los
fenómenos naturales y las actividades
humanas en el clima y parís y descubrió
patrones ocultos en materiales complejos
desordenados el nobel de química fue
para david macmillan y benjamin list dos
investigadores que desarrollaron la
llamada órgano catálisis asimétrica una
técnica que usa pequeñas moléculas
orgánicas como catalizadores lo primero
que hay que decir es que una catálisis
es la variación de la velocidad en una
reacción química producida por la
presencia de un catalizador
durante mucho tiempo se pensó que solo
los metales y las enzimas eran
catalizadores es decir podían acelerar o
retardar una reacción química pues ellos
dos desarrollaron de manera
independiente una nueva forma de
catálisis mcmillan usó moléculas
orgánicas simples y liszt empleó un
aminoácido llamado prolina
el premio es por desarrollar un método
para crear moléculas para sintetizar
moléculas
de milán los galardonados descubrieron
un método para hacer moléculas más
baratos simple y ambientalmente amigable
en particular en la industria médica
para fabricar medicamentos es muy
importante porque el cuerpo puede
reaccionar diferente a diferentes
moléculas y con este método llamado
órgano catálisis puedes hacer moléculas
específicas lo que es extremadamente
importante
continuamos ahora en alemania porque fue
inaugurada la que según sus responsables
es la primera fábrica comercial capaz de
producir queroseno sintético una
sustancia calificada como el combustible
sostenible del futuro mientras que los
autos y otras formas de transporte están
siendo electrificadas desarrollar un
avión que funcione con baterías es un
reto mucho mayor por eso los expertos
indican que los combustibles ecológicos
son la solución más accesible por el
momento
el queroseno ecológico es básicamente
hidrocarburos es decir todo es hidrógeno
el carbono por lo tanto se necesitan
esos dos recursos que se unen en un gas
de síntesis y luego produce cadenas de
hidrocarburos sintéticos censados el
proyecto se llama atmósfera y sus
desarrolladores indican que la quema de
queroseno sintético únicamente libera la
atmósfera la cantidad de gas carbónico
que se eliminó previamente para
producirlo lo que lo convierte en
carbono neutral en principio se podrán
producir unos 8 barriles por día lo que
equivale a 336 galones de combustible
para aviones que alcanzarían para llenar
un pequeño avión de pasajeros cada tres
semanas
proyectos de bien por proyecto es muy
importante porque muestra que la
neutralidad de carbono en 2045 también
es posible en la aviación
necesitamos soñar con ello la gente
quiere volar así que tiene que ser
sostenible y eso muestra que después de
eso
tenemos mucho conocimiento y toda la
tecnología necesaria para hacer
sea sostenible con los combustibles
ecológicos y con el queroseno vehículos
y kurz dyn
continuamos con otra iniciativa amigable
con el medio ambiente pero que también
puede fascinar a los amantes de los
diamantes las gafas de sol y la ropa
deportiva de alta gama entre otros todos
estos productos pueden fabricarse con
dióxido de carbono sabemos que este gas
está compuesto por una molécula de
carbono y dos de oxígeno pues varias
compañías están capturando el carbono
del ambiente para desarrollar sus
productos lo que es único de los
diamantes éter es de donde viene somos
los primeros y únicos productores del
planeta que fabricamos diamantes con
carbono capturado eso significa que cada
átomo de carbono que componen nuestros
diamantes antes estaba calentando el
planeta a diferencia de los diamantes
hechos en laboratorio y los diamantes
extraídos no estamos aquí sentados
peleando sobre qué proceso daña - el
planeta le dimos la vuelta al paradigma
y producimos diamantes que dan un
beneficio tangible algunas estimaciones
de la onu para 2050 el mundo necesitará
capturar del ambiente 10 mil millones de
toneladas de dióxido de carbono
anualmente para frenar el calentamiento
global
los productos de origen fósil que
podrían usar carbono reciclado
representan unas 6 mil 800 millones de
toneladas en emisiones pues una de las
empresas pioneras en capturar el carbono
del aire que aún es una novedad se llama
twelve y sus responsables aseguran que
la tecnología que usan es clave para
reciclar está molécula
me está interesando solo agua y
electricidad renovable nuestro
catalizador puede deconstruir el dióxido
de carbono y reformar esos elementos en
compuestos esenciales a base de carbono
como plásticos combustibles cosas de las
que dependemos cada día y si no
tuviéramos ese tipo de tecnología
tendríamos que continuar usando carbón
fósil como petróleo o gas natural que
eventualmente agregan más gas carbónico
a la atmósfera llegamos hacia el final
de este espacio pero les recordamos que
pueden repetir esta y otras emisiones en
nuestra web france24 puntocom
sí